today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
it feels like it was certainly days ago
if not a week ago that i was warning you
that these paramilitaries in portland
oregon were just step one
in a sort of trial balloon for donald
trump to deploy
federal troops to more cities against
the desires of state and local
authorities against the desires of
mayors
but that was yesterday it was just 16 17
hours ago since our clip published about
these paramilitaries in portland being
just
stepped like 0.5 and donald trump
yesterday announced a plan to deploy
more troops to the city of chicago now
directly counter to the desires of the
mayor lori lightfoot so let's take a
look
first at what donald trump said
yesterday announcing this
every american no matter their income
their race or their zip code should be
able to walk their city streets
free from violence and free from fear
for this reason today i am announcing
that the department of justice will
immediately surge
federal law enforcement to the city of
chicago
the fbi atf dea
u.s marshals service and homeland
security will together be sending
hundreds of skilled law enforcement
officers to chicago to help drive down
violent crime and murderers and violent
criminals are breaking a wide range of
federal laws
we have that it's as wide as it can be
we will find them arrest them and
prosecute them
they will be in jail for many years to
come now
there are about four or five different
issues here so first let's deal with
the propaganda optics this idea
of crime in liberal democrat cities as
trump likes to say
is being used to justify donald trump's
reelection now you might wonder well
hold on that doesn't doesn't seem
obvious like crime in liberal democrat
cities
trump reelection paramilitaries in the
middle what's the path
the path is weak democrats who run
liberal democrat cities aren't about law
and order
and you're going to get more of this if
joe biden
were to win now on the other hand you've
got donald trump donald trump is the
law and order guy he won't hesitate
to send in the troops not metaphorically
but literally
to enforce the law as they say now
there's a lot missing from this
narrative first of all remember
that there's an urban rural divide in
the united states so when we hear the
right say
look at all these cities with high crime
that are all run by
democrats well remember crime tends to
be where you have people
uh in greater population density so by
definition the crime is mostly going to
be in cities
and cities are more liberal than rural
areas so you are disproportionately
going to have democrats running cities
both cities that have higher crime and
lower crime so
it's essentially a non-factor but it's
being used at number one to start the
propaganda
now what's also missing from this
narrative is that right now
we have a huge amount of economic
desperation we have every week
we have two to ten times the new
unemployment claims
that previously were the record remember
the record previously was like 650 675
000 jobless claims in a week we've had
anywhere from you know 1.3 million
to six and a half million claims per
week for the last 16 17 weeks of this
pandemic
so we have the economic destruction of
coronavirus
which yes partially uh relates to donald
trump's failed response which is also a
factor
in the desperation we are seeing that is
leading to some crime and then
you know at least in portland part of
the escalation intentions and violence
is because of these unbadged
paramilitaries
showing up against the desires of local
authorities
and throwing people into unmarked vans
and that's also
part of the play here so the idea is
send in troops
to cause and foment confrontations in
order to then justify saying well we've
got to send them to chicago as well
because look at what happened in
portland well part of what happened in
portland is because
you sent in the troops now i already
went over the legal part yesterday
but it bears some repeating in case
people see this clip and not that clip
the statute that the trump
administration is citing
as what gives them the right to do this
very clearly says
that this author i believe it's 40 u.s
code 1315
but i i may be misremembering it says
the authority to send in federal law
enforcement
is lim unilaterally is limited to
protecting buildings that are either
owned by the federal government
or a building that the federal
government is using for an office so
there might be a local landlord that
owns a building
but there's some federal government
office that is in there
that is the limit of what the federal
government can go in and do now if they
want to go beyond federal property
they may seek to get agreement with
state and local authorities
they can work concurrently with state
and local authorities if state and local
authorities want
that's not what's happening in portland
portland and now chicago the mayors
do not want them there they are not
working with local law enforcement so
their legal justification
is absolutely and completely bogus now
let's step back for a second
if this was happening in a different
country
there are many prior administrations
both republicans and democrats that
would say we can't allow that to happen
in another country
here is donald trump and i'm not saying
we would send in our troops to stop it
at another country but we would speak
out and say that's not okay
um here is donald trump doing this
himself domestically okay so understand
the contrast here
every conservative as much as every
liberal should be disgusted by this and
as i've said before
we're really six weeks from the election
in the sense that the first
early ballots and absentee ballots can
start coming in in a few states
in six weeks so this is a strategy from
a desperate president
to create chaos and use the chaos he
creates
to justify keeping the armed troops
sending in more
armed troops in major cities up through
to and including the election
in order to intimidate voters to incite
trump supporters to lay the groundwork
to then question the results of the
election now there's a lot there
not every aspect of that will
necessarily happen but that's the big
picture of why this
is happening this is exactly what i said
yesterday
and monday and late last week was going
to happen and we're now going from just
portland to portland and chicago and
there's discussions of more cities as
well so
this is not a test guys this is no joke
this this is it this is no longer the
rehearsal
it's happening right now and i said in a
segment on tuesday
that a desperate trump is a dangerous
trump
we are seeing that front and center
right now and this is about so much more
than
just this election this is about so much
more than
uh a sort of acute republican hypocrisy
this is about morality this is about
the constitution which the right claims
to hold almost as a sacred text
this is about states rights uh being
violated in fact
this is about a whole bunch of things
that the right claims to care about
and by the way you know i i if i ignore
this last
bit of a dog whistle i would not be be
thorough
chicago is part of the dog whistle right
because republicans for years have been
sort of using this um dog whistle
imagery of dangerous violent black urban
youths in chicago
sending the troops there next is
part of the dog whistle to continue
inciting
those exact same images and that is
exactly what we are seeing here
it is dog whistle politics it is a man
acting out of desperation
and i would be wrong if i said it
definitely won't work there's a chance
and that's why this is so important
there's a chance that not only will this
be morally wrong
and legally wrong there's a chance that
this actually will help
donald trump tweeting this is you know
images from portland saying
this is what joe biden's america would
look like now what's crazy is
it's actually trumps america but this is
the type of imagery that actually can
work it's very ugly
listen we saw i mean when it looked like
benjamin netanyahu in israel
was maybe going to go down this was
years ago now not in the most recent
election
uh it was this type of ex this exact
same type of imagery and fear-mongering
that ultimately got him re-elected okay
so so writing this off as it definitely
won't work
uh is not right we would be wrong to do
that let me know what your thoughts are
i'm on twitter at dpakman
we have a lot of things to go over with
you today so we're keeping this first
part of the show a little shorter i
accidentally clapped there that was
weird
um and and we will be uh right back
momentarily with so much more that we
have to discuss today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay um today's new members of the day
are joaquin aguilar and katherine
kritzberg
i also want to thank lloyd fletcher
who's today's long time sustaining
member of the day
but i don't want to spend too much time
today on membership
because we have so much to discuss you
can grab a membership at joinpackman.com
we do have a discussion forum where more
than
21 000 of our viewers and listeners are
now subscribed it's all free
davidpakman.com reddit a few
uh posts and topics of interest that i
spotted this morning that i do want to
discuss with you
user stilo 14 posted the white house has
announced trump will resume
coronavirus press briefings why was
there a hiatus and why are they all of a
sudden coming back so
essentially the the answer to both
questions is sort of the same except the
perspective was changed the hiatus
started because the white house wanted
to portray coronavirus as being over
so one of the ways to portray
coronavirus being over is saying
we no longer need to do daily white
house press briefings
the press briefings were also doing
damage in the sense that at one of the
last ones before the break donald trump
wondered out loud about injecting
hitting the body as he says with
isopropyl
alcohol and bleach to treat coronavirus
disaster and so the idea was let's stop
the briefings in order to help trump
by pretending coronavirus is over that
didn't work
and the first wave never ended and now
we are actually back to over a thousand
deaths a day we are at 60 70
000 cases a day maybe in the direction
of a hundred thousand cases a day
so for the same reason because things
are going well trump is going back to
try to improve his approval he stopped
the press briefings to try to improve
his approval
he's now restarting them to try to
improve his approval and it has been
sort of a different trump that has shown
up
saying uh you know masks are important
taking the mask out of his pocket which
he keeps with him as a prop all the time
now
saying it may get worse before it gets
better a very different tone than we
have 15 cases which will soon be zero we
now have by the way
4.1 million cumulative cases
so i don't know whether this will make
an impact at this point it may be too
little too late but the reason that
there was a hiatus
is the same reason that the white house
coronavirus press briefings are now
back also from the david pakman show
subreddit user
katie all the time posted what happens
if many refuse the coronavirus vaccine
should it come out saying right now dr
fauci says getting hurt immunity
might not be possible due to our
anti-vaxx
anti-science and anti-authority
sentiment
unfortunately he is right
you're going to have to convince people
who may normally be pro-vaccine
but are scared the vaccine was rushed
through
this is a serious issue i mean there's
no other way around it the united states
is uniquely dropping the ball on
coronavirus
and it's not that anti-vaxx is only
present in the united states
but there are some big enclaves of it
here and um the
the level of immunity you need to get
hurt immunity varies based on how
contagious
something is so for example measles is
so contagious
i think it has a reproduction value an r
naught of
i think it's somewhere between 16 and
18. and when something has a 16 to 18
r naught you need like 95 of the
population to be immune to be vaccinated
in order to have herd immunity now
coronavirus is not as contagious
as measles of course uh but at
coronavirus's level of of spreadability
of contagion
the estimates are you need about 70
immunity now we're only at like one two
percent
from people who have recovered from the
virus and we don't even know how long
that immunity lasts
at this point so you are going to need a
lot of people to get the vaccine and
some significant portion has already
said they probably won't so
i don't have a solution but this user on
our subreddit is correctly pointing out
that we may be up against a real problem
here if and when the vaccine is
available and if and when we determine
that the vaccine
creates a sturdy immune response
the anti-vax movement and some people
who are just going to be worried because
of hey
this vaccine was developed quicker than
any other vaccine
maybe it's not safe even though of
course safety trials are like the first
hurdle that it has to get through
i don't have an answer unfortunately
katie but that that is likely to be a
problem
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t okay i have video for you
today that is truly like
nothing i have ever seen before donald
trump was interviewed on fox news
and he tried to explain the genesis
of getting a cognitive assessment and
brag about the results and i have to
tell you
this interview performance by donald
trump only raises more questions
about his cognitive state you really
have to hear this now remember the
context is
sunday during an interview with fox
news's chris wallace the topic of
trump's cognitive test and cognitive
state came up
chris wallace pointed out according to a
new poll people are more confident in
joe biden's cognitive state than donald
trump's
and donald trump really reacted very
strangely he told chris wallace on
sunday that
he would uh that joe biden wouldn't do
as well as trump did on a cognitive test
when wallace pointed out you know that
test is pretty easy it was like
identify a drawing of an elephant trump
said well
the last five questions are really tough
and trump even said to chris wallace
that wallace himself wouldn't do super
well on the test which is
i mean it's just absolutely insane so
cut to yesterday trump is interviewed by
fox news
and we've got to go through it piece by
piece and you'll see this is really
something else let's just jump right in
trump's starting out by saying he sought
out a cognitive test
in order to prove his critics wrong he
immediately goes off the rails into
these tangents of free association a
sort of verbal inkblot test so the last
time i was at the hospital
probably a year ago a little less than a
year ago i asked the doctor i said is
there some kind of a
cognitive test that i could take because
i've been hearing about it
because i want to shut these people up
they're made they're fake news they make
up
stories i mean like i'll do an interview
with you you i didn't say you can't ask
me about this you can
i say ask me anything i did one with
chris wallace he was nice enough to say
he said i just want to tell the audience
there was no question
that's offbounds okay and he's a tough
cookie and it was a good interview i
liked it i enjoyed it
and it was good but i didn't say you can
only ask this you can only
we have to be sharp if you're in the
office of the presidency we have to be
sure
so they were saying all these different
things it was going all over whichever
stuck
none of it stuck fortunately but one of
the reasons it didn't is that i took a
test
i said to the doctor it was dr ronny
jackson i said is there some kind of a
test
an acuity test and he said there
actually is and he named it whatever it
might be
and it was 30 or 35 questions the first
questions are very easy
the last questions are much more
difficult okay so let's stop there
trump says he did this a year or less
than a year ago
in january of 2018 was when we reported
that trump took the montreal cognitive
assessment and claims to have scored a
perfect score on it
so if trump is referring to that test as
being less than a year ago
that's weird did he take another test
more recently
we don't know but as far as we were told
trump's last cognitive test was two and
a half years ago trump says it was
recent like
unless uh more recently than the last
year that's another one of these
questions now he also mentions he did it
with dr ronnie jackson dr ronny jackson
as far as i recall
was already gone in march or april of
2018. so it would be very weird for
trump to be saying i took this less than
a year ago
with dr ronnie jackson because ronnie
jackson was gone at that point in time
it's weird trump also says that it's 30
or 35
questions well if it is the montreal
cognitive assessment it's out of 30
points
it's certainly not 30 questions
depending on what you consider a
question it's
sort of like 15 different exercises
again the last ones are not difficult
but let's continue because then trump
gets into that and this is maybe the
most interesting part
uh like a memory question it's uh like
you'll go person
woman man camera
tv so they say could you repeat that
so i said yeah so it's person woman
man camera tv now this is absolutely
fascinating
trump gives examples of the memory part
he says
you know you have to remember five words
person woman man camera tv
now what trump is doing there is he's
grouping or chunking the terms
by theme and he's clearly just looking
around
and you know he was talking to a man
there must have been a woman
you know maybe off camera he says camera
tv that actually raises more questions
about trump's cognitive state because
the way this would normally be done is
with unrelated terms the examples in the
sample test that we have
and are showing our audience the example
words are face
velvet church daisy red so again the
words are not related
and the fact that trump found that
question difficult and
maybe he even got an easier version
right like in other words
if trump's five words that he was given
were related
that is also very strange that he would
find it difficult
so trump is just picking things around
him that makes it a way easier question
and again it shouldn't be particularly
tough let's continue
okay that's very good if you get it in
order you get extra points if you
okay now he's asking you other questions
other questions
and then 10 minutes 15 20 minutes later
they say
remember the first question not the
first but the tenth question
give us that again can you do that again
and you go person
woman man camera tv
if you get it in order you get extra
points
they said nobody gets it in order it's
actually not that easy but for me it was
easy
so here it truly sounds like trump
is being treated like a difficult child
what a good boy you got the words
not only did you get the words right
donnie you got them in order here's a
lolly and a sticker to put on your shirt
no one gets them in order trump says
does
does anybody understand how insane it is
that trump is bragging about this and he
actually keeps going
and that's not an easy question in other
words
they ask it to you they give you five
names and you have to repeat them
and that's okay if you repeat them out
of order
it's okay but but you know it's not as
good
but then when you go back about 20 25
minutes later and they say go back to
the network they don't tell you this
now the interviewer despite not really
questioning what trump is saying
visibly looks shell-shocked by what
donald trump is talking about but i'm
not giving the guy credit he could have
challenged any single one of these
assertions and he didn't
and then trump portrays passing the test
as if he just you know spliced the atom
or something it's stunning
you know if you take this test we may
have to reveal that i said it's all
right i've been
is it tough tell me about never heard of
it
and i got a perfect mark
and the doctors were they said very few
people
can do that very few people get that you
understand it's not that easy there were
other questions tougher than what i just
did
now there trump says that there were
even harder questions than remembering
five words there really aren't i mean
what
there's this question where as an
example you start with a hundred and
then they tell you
count backwards by by seven from a
hundred so you go okay 193
86 79 72 etc
maybe that's what trump is referring to
there's another one which is like name
as many words as you can in a minute
that start with the letter d
and you've got to go you know dog doofus
depraved dilapidate you know it's
you you get it so there really aren't
more difficult questions
and that's also weird that trump is
bringing up
and then just one more clip here but
it's not that easy
but as soon as they announced my score
and their test
all the stuff went away about me is
incompetent remember they're talking
about 25th amendment and nonsense
and they said wow and even the enemies
they don't
say that anymore but they do say it
about
joe biden and honestly he should take
the test in a way as an obligation to
because you have to be able to
show this country that the person that
we're picking as leader
is sharp now of course the concerns
didn't go away when trump took the test
in fact taking that test has raised
even more questions and trump's
commentary on the test has raised even
more questions
this is one of the strangest overall
timelines that we've been in for
american public politics
certainly since i've had the david
pakman show certainly since i've been
following politics and even really that
i can remember while i was alive
this is outrageous it's outrageous
what's going on and another strange
thing is that trump now says
the reason he sought out the test was to
disprove claims of cognitive decline
he never said that at the time it's
another inconsistency but it also tells
us
trump clearly is following these
narratives that are appearing primarily
on independent media
and i know we've joked around before
about indications that
either don jr or donald trump may have
seen segments of the david pakman show
i'm not claiming that that's the case
and i i've no it's certainly conceivable
but but i have no idea
although i am aware of some aides at the
white house that are certainly aware of
the show
but what's clear is even when these
things don't appear on corporate media
and we say you know corporate media
really should be talking about
x y or z the cognitive stuff has only
appeared on corporate media in the last
couple of months
years ago independent media was talking
about it and it is very clear that
donald trump
was aware of it and that also is
interesting it's not just fox news
that is sort of informing donald trump's
understanding and
lastly trump still keeps talking about
these cognitive tests as if they're kind
of like iq type memory games
rather than just crude screenings for
dementia everything about it is
outrageous and we'll have
probably a poll question about this on
our instagram page so make sure you are
following us there
at uh david pakman show on instagram
and if you happen to pull up your
instagram app on your phone
you might as well give me a follow you
can check out my urban backyard garden
and a lot of other wacky things
i'm david.packman on instagram
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay this is super interesting i must
have gotten 10 or 12 emails and tweets
from people saying david you have to
cover the discussion that took place
yesterday between joe rogan
and ben shapiro and um
i looked at it and it is super
interesting and i want to talk about it
right wing darling
ben shapiro was on joe rogan's program
yesterday
and there was a really interesting
discussion about
historical racism in the united states
systemic racism reasons for
unequal outcomes in the united states
today along racial lines and
it actually is a very uh relevant
conversation about systemic racism and i
have to tell you ben shapiro actually
does make some important concessions
here
although he always hides them in the
right wing talking points that that he's
very much attached to and he probably
would have gotten away with a lot more
of it had joe rogan not pushed back so
let's just
jump right in and i'll comment as we go
i don't know that we need that much
introduction
is there middle ground d so
if we look at 1776 and we look at the
declaration of independence and we look
at america today in 2020
there clearly is some impact
in the echoes of slavery and then after
that jim crow there's clearly
some impact in these deeply impoverished
communities that don't seem to advance
yes so the to to make the argument about
institutional racism there's a couple
ways you can read this when people say
systemic racism or institutional racism
i usually ask them to be a little more
specific in what they mean because there
are a few ways you can read that one is
history has impact of course that's true
right that's true for everybody
it's true in your family history if you
have a grandfather who
went to who went to prison on a
particular charge that leads to poverty
for your parents which led to more
poverty for you right
people have histories those histories
are embedded in their life experiences
and that's true for societies as well
all of that is for sure true
then there's the question as to whether
the institutions today are racist
and that's not quite the same thing
right because history has consequences
is not the same thing as saying the
rules today are racist
because the rules today are not racist
actually the rules today are quite not
racist so this part of the conversation
is very well illustrated by what i call
a monopoly
monopoly analogy where it's about
the what the rules are now versus the
historical impact so here's the monopoly
analogy which applies to
people like ben shapiro saying listen
we've fixed the rules
we fixed the problem because the rules
now are no longer racist so
with monopoly everybody starts with the
same amount of money
and the same amount of property which is
zero at the beginning of the game
but imagine that three players hang
around and play monopoly for an hour
and they start buying up the properties
and driving up the rents and putting
houses and hotels on the properties and
the utilities are owned park place
boardwalk you guys all know monopoly
and then a fourth player comes in and
everybody's playing by the same rules
that fourth player gets the same amount
of money
the fourth player is allowed to buy any
property that they want the fourth
player is bound to pay rent if they land
on a square that is owned by a different
player
so the rules are exactly the same for
everybody they are they are equitable
rules
but the fact that you were starting
after
a bunch of the properties have been
bought up and the rents have been
increased
is a very much uh it's a it's a
an analogy to what we are talking about
today in terms of how we fix
the law when it comes to race and how we
properly dealt with
historical issues that are still
relevant today
so for example we now have hiring
non-discrimination laws you're not
allowed to
there's no lower minimum wage for black
or hispanic workers
legally there's no you're not allowed to
say we only hire white people here right
that
that has been fixed so to speak but you
still have historic or redlining
and um uh disproportionately people of
color
living in neighborhoods that were
previously areas
where folks were pushed to when they
were not white and that relates to the
public transit system in a way that
makes it more difficult on average to
get to
where where the better jobs are so even
if the employer
can no longer discriminate and say we
prefer not to hire black people
or hispanic people or whatever you have
all of this historical stuff which is
still very relevant
um so then the question becomes well
what if anything should we be doing
about it and then
joe rogan pushes back again so but
historically
it's fairly recent if you go from the
civil rights movement to 2020
we're really not talking about that much
time it's about three generations
50 plus years 60 years yeah i mean it's
50 plus right
in the world of you know in the best fan
of human history
it's not a very small amount of time
right so clearly there's some
impact of both racism and then jim crow
laws
so that that's where i'm saying there's
a middle ground yeah
and it's independent it is important for
people on my side of the conservatives
to
acknowledge and recognize the importance
of of history
in people's living situations now and
it's important for people on the other
side of the aisle to at the same time
not attribute every single thing
to history because right but people who
believe something like that
there's always like extremes on each
position
and the truth lies somewhere in the
middle yeah but i don't think that it
lies as far
in in the dead center of that as people
i think want it to
so this is already an important
admission by ben shapiro he says
there is a balance there's a balance
between historical impacts and personal
responsibility
it's not just about personal
responsibility now of course ben
says it's not 50 50. and that's where
the argument is well
is it 80 historical discrimination and
20 percent personal
agency or is it 70 personal in 30
history we would very much disagree but
it's an important concession that joe
rogan
extracts from ben shapiro here now let's
skip ahead a little bit and you're going
to see
that despite making the concession ben
jumps right back into
this is mostly just black people have to
decide for themselves that they're going
to improve their lives and fix the
situation so
despite the concession he still goes
back to that the
the way to fight against that is to make
good decisions
and so the you fight against the system
to make sure that the system has
rules that apply equally to everyone
right but you clearly see that there's a
big difference between people coming
over here willingly
and doing so in order to better their
lives versus someone
whose ancestors were dragged over here
to be sold as property
and then dealing with the repercussions
of that being your family history
and redline laws and all the other
things that were put in place to sort of
keep them in very specific areas which
to this day remain crime-ridden
gang-ridden
deeply impoverished communities well
that's true but the question is how much
of that is historic redlining and how
much of that is an 18 year old kid today
deciding to pipe a gun and shoot
somebody
but how much of that 18 year old kid
today deciding to pick up a gun and
shoot somebody is based on him
growing up in this [ __ ] up environment
where that's what he models where
everything around him is crime
and gangs and you imitate your
atmosphere which what all humans do
right but the answer is there's only one
way to break that chain
what what way is that that way is to not
pick up a gun and shoot somebody i think
a simplistic way of looking at it if
you're on the outside of that community
and you're not one of those 18 year old
kids that grows up
with the incredible influence of all the
people around him and that's all you see
and that's all you know well but the
problem is the only way that's going to
be
the thing that your kid doesn't know is
for you not to do it at some point
personal agency has to come in some
it does because the expectation
education and and teaching
them about personal agency and and
letting them
understand that there's a way out of
this and that the path that they see
being replicated over and over again by
these people that wind up dying young
that wind up going to jail
that there are other options so ben is
saying now
the only way out is personal agency each
individual
has to just fix the situation for
themselves and say
i am going to change stuff now one of
the reasons why
uh ben is successful is that
he says things that on a superficial
practical level sounds so obvious and
that's where
he gets this reputation if he just tells
it like it is you know facts don't care
about your feelings
on a very practical level yes if an
individual takes a different action
then they improve their situation the
problem is that if you fall for that
idea
it pushes us to having to say
the country no longer has any
responsibility when ben shapiro says
the only way out is personal agency it
means the country as a whole
all of us can essentially wash our hands
of history and say
just personal agency they just need to
fix it themselves
but here as joe rogan points out we have
to enable
people to do that we have to set people
up
to do that there's a lot of kids that
never get that other information or if
they get it
they get little blips of it but the vast
majority of the information the vast
majority of the influence they get is
terrible well
i totally agree with this and this is
why i think the worst thing that you can
say to a kid
is you're born behind the eight ball and
no matter what you do you're not gonna
succeed
right that's literally the worst thing
you say to a kid what you should be
saying is look at how your grandfather
was born behind the eightfall and look
how hard he had to work in order to get
ahead
and look at all the opportunities that's
true though but if your grandfather
wasn't ahead didn't get ahead if your
grandfather was in and out of jail
if your father was in and out of jail
everyone around you is like that if
there's
literally no influence that's positive
in your life
the idea of saying to a kid like that
hey don't pick up a gun and shoot
somebody
it's way that's way too simplistic a
version
of their future in my mind i mean the
problem is i don't see an alternative
solution
so joe rogan rightly points out ben's
idea of pointing to grandpa or dad
and saying there is another path look at
what grandpa did look at what dad did
that only works when grandpa or dad are
actually
examples of that and that's the problem
if grandpa or dad were already examples
that you want to live up to
we wouldn't have the problem we have on
our hands sometimes grandpa and dad
aren't the right examples and that is
exactly
what joe rogan is pointing out and ben
says well i just don't see an
alternative solution
and of course there are endless
alternative solutions
now this is typically where folks like
ben and others will say
reparations won't fix this and that's
often a straw man
i'm not even thinking of reparations and
it is actually
true that whether you can make a moral
case for handing cash to people
is not at issue because just handing
cash to people won't actually fix the
issues
joe rogan is talking about here we need
to go further than
are the rules racist on paper today
and ben is right that on paper the rules
are mostly not racist today but that's a
way to wash our hands of the problem to
say we fix the rules
and they're now fine and that's it well
that runs into the monopoly paradox
that i outlined earlier so now we
actually need to do the tough work of
figuring out
what's the right way to go forward
now that we fix the rules on paper
fixing the rules on paper is step one
right it's not
the solution and there's the historical
piece that joe rogan points out now just
one more brief element here
the topic of colin kaepernick kneeling
came up
in sort of a weird way let's just take a
look at it and i have a few thoughts
about it
like when people say it's hard to make
money in this country there
are a lot of people making money a lot
of different ways yes in this country
and i mean for god's sake colin
kaepernick is making millions of dollars
kneeling for the national anthem it
feels like and calling america racist
while cashing the check this is a great
damned country
well we're now we're getting into with
the weeds
i just wanted to talk about girls
ripping dudes off i know you did but we
can go back there man
that's okay but the colin kaepernick
thing
all right don't you think that
at least some good has come out of
him doing that where it's sort of
raised awareness for police brutality
just let it just put it to the forefront
let people
like let people understand that this is
a problem
no no no no no because i think that he
made
a serious error which is that the most
positive movements in american social
history
have been ones that don't kneel for the
flag but say in the name of the flag you
should do x
right so martin luther king said in the
name of the flag civil rights are
necessary
so the problem with ben's idea that
instead of kneeling
you say in the name of the flag we
should do x or y
you know he gives us this nice martin
luther king example which sounds great
and of course ben is smart by giving
that example
as the right winger oh he's talking
about martin luther king that's great
that he did the right thing
but how many people have said in the
name of the flag
we should shut up and support our troops
in fighting this war
2003 that was happening with the iraq
war do the patriotic thing in the name
of the flag
support the troops in their mission in
iraq which we went into
ridiculously because saudi arabians
attacked us on 911 what
that didn't make sense hey don't kneel
just in the name of the flag
ask for support well that's what people
did when it came to the iraq war
and that's a very very dangerous
direction to go in so this is
interesting on a few different
a few different levels um you can check
out the the entire exchange which is
about 20 minutes you know we played four
or five of
the minutes here um i i do think that it
is um a step forward in a sense that
we got the admission from ben shapiro
that there is a balance
between personal responsibility and the
historical realities
i would vehemently disagree with him
about where the balance likely is
but a very interesting conversation and
a relevant one and
interestingly a lot of dislikes for this
appearance by ben shapiro but i don't
know
if the dislikes were from people who
disagree with ben shapiro
or from people who weren't pleased with
joe rogan's position
as many of you may know whenever i go on
joe rogan's program
brutal brutal dislikes and uh
my instinct is it's people saying they
don't like
my views but i don't know if that's
necessarily
where the dislikes came from for this
ben shapiro discussion with joe rogan i
just don't know
and it would be interesting uh to think
about let's take a quick break
we have so much more to discuss coming
up
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well
read about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
at the absolute very beginning of
coronavirus we would sort of joke but we
weren't really fully joking that at some
point they would just try to blame obama
for coronavirus they being the trump
administration
and trumpists and of course we very
quickly realized it wasn't a joke when
they started to do it eventually we
started
to hear this phrase from donald trump
the cupboards were left
bare by barack obama uh bear of what
exactly it was not ever totally clear it
was ppe
or ventilators there were no tests but
of course there was no coronavirus so
how could you have a test for it
and of course absurdity aside donald
trump did have
three years if indeed he was left bare
cupboards by barack obama which he
wasn't
he was left three years to refill those
cover
cupboards before coronavirus hit now in
reality there were 19 000 ventilators in
the national stockpile when barack obama
left office
etc etc but there were three years
during which trump could have refilled
anything that was empty
they are now going full mask off
as we would call it here is tim murtagh
or murtuff i'm not exactly
murtaugh donald trump's 2020
communications director
on cnn just blaming obama just blaming
obama for what's now going on with
coronavirus take a look
if people were saying don't wear masks
because medical professionals will need
them and there might be a shortage
it's because the national stockpile had
been depleted but that's when the
president enlisted the the
role of the private sector and got the
whole of america into the production of
masks and other ppe
and i would point out ventilators you
remember at the beginning of this entire
process
we heard an awful lot out of new york
and california and other states
about what they perceive to be a looming
shortage of ventilators
that shortage never materialized because
the president strategically
left 19 000 ventilators you know
tim obama left 19 000 ventilators in the
plan so you're lying
and you don't you're talking like you're
talking like it's 2017.
it's 2020 sir it is 2020.
it has been almost four years hold on a
second let's let's talk about this for a
second
so here it's ventilators and ppe which
obama didn't leave us
now of course obama did certainly leave
us ventilators
and ppe as well
but there were three years during which
trump could have boosted those supplies
but
trump insists no one could have seen
this coming so
if no one could have seen it coming how
could you possibly blame obama
but if someone could have seen this
coming even if it's partially obama's
fault
trump had three years to get ventilators
and ppe
if he saw it coming so you can't be on
one side of that without being
on the other if no one could see it
coming then certainly
it's no more obama's fault than donald
trump's and if you could have seen it
coming
then even if obama did something wrong
trump also
did something wrong by spending three
years not
preparing for a problem that we could
have seen coming so you've got to be on
one side
or the other of that they're trying to
be on both sides so then this guy tim
murda changes tact and talks instead
about testing and that just really
didn't go well
the testing program that the president
has instituted here in this country
we've tested almost 46 million americans
and the reason and what testing program
the reason why a testing program that
the president has
instituted is because this hold on a
second hold on a second the reason why a
testing program for the coronavirus
didn't it's not a federal
program because there was there was no
test listen to this there was no test
for the coronavirus because prior to
this
there was no corona virus the test had
to be invented
first so now tim tim goes to
trump-built testing because coronavirus
is new and the test had to be invented
but that's true in every country tim and
yet most other countries scaled up
testing per capita much faster
they try to pretend that this is unique
to the united states
the origin was china for every country
around the world
there were no tests for every country
around the world it's not
unique to the united states the sudden
need for testing
for a new virus was the case in every
country it was the case in south
korea and italy and taiwan and greece
and everywhere we were just one of the
slowest and this really doesn't get much
better
before it could be mass produced and
spread around the country and that's
what the president has achieved 46
million tests have been conducted in
this country
we're now testing 800 000 people a day
and that is a wide spread and they take
two weeks that did not previously know
that according to
the netherlands hold on a second if you
don't test get the results back within
five days those tests are pointless i
mean this is a testing failure time
and the pres hold on a second and the
president no it is not it's actually a
tremendous success story we're leading
the world in testing
it's so boring that they're still doing
this
leading the world in testing we have 330
million people
the total number of tests is not super
relevant
when you think about per capita but i'm
actually going to going to say something
that i've started to say on live streams
at this point even looking at per capita
is less relevant because a lot of places
don't really need tests anymore since so
few people
have the virus and what i mean by that
is we've now for example caught up to
spain in testing per capita and we've
passed
spain in tests per capita well
spain no longer needs to do very much
testing
because they've completely flattened the
curve so of course we're passing other
countries in testing per capita now
in the last few days spain has started
to see an uptick in cases
and that's another issue that we're
seeing in a few european countries which
we're going to follow
let's watch a little bit more here 46
million tests
of americans and eight hundred thousand
tests a day
there's also improvements going on
they're allowed hold on a second they're
allowing people to now be
i can't hold on a second at a time
you did a pretty nice job by brianna
keeler
there so if this is one of those
situations where
if the facts presented by tim murtagh
were true
trump had years to replenish empty
cupboards and all of that stuff
but tim murdoch's arguments aren't even
real because the facts are not
as he describes and this is what we're
essentially down to now
repeating the same lies over and over
again
and hoping that people are uh
accepting it as the truth so that donald
trump can get himself re-elected that's
what at the core of everything that's
what's at the core of trump now carrying
his mask with him as a propaganda
showpiece all the time
this is what's at the core of trump now
saying it may get worse before it gets
better
and taking a new tone and all of this
difference the the portland and chicago
deployments of troops
all the singular focus at this point for
this administration and people like tim
murdah
is just getting trump reelected in
november by any means necessary
hey this so this next story is not the
biggest story but i
i do like something that nancy pelosi is
doing because it's fighting donald trump
with his own tactics
in a way that's not immoral now i've
pointed out many times before
we are trying to fight the immorality of
the right we are trying to fight the
destructive impulses of the right
we don't want to fight those destructive
immoral
impulses by being destructive and
immoral ourselves
so on a lot of policy-based things i've
made it very clear
we should not stoop to their level we we
don't the country doesn't benefit in the
long run
from the left becoming just as
destructive and immoral as the right
merely to justify replacing the right
however there are some optics
elements where i actually think it's
okay
to adopt some of the strategies of trump
and one of these is nancy pelosi
starting to refer to the coronavirus as
the trump virus
now a few weeks ago i jokingly uh
tweeted we should really call it trump
cov20 and some people liked it some
people didn't
but really the idea is we have to brand
trump with the failure we have to brand
the failure with donald trump's name
and nancy pelosi is doing it this
doesn't mean nancy pelosi is a
progressive
this doesn't mean anything other than
nancy pelosi
is using one of trump's more innocuous
techniques
against trump and i know there are
people who are going to flippantly say
okay nancy
you know trump virus is clever but what
about getting people relief money
i agree right i'm not saying that this
is a replacement or an excuse
for anything but i do think that
fighting trump's
you know kung flu stuff uh with some of
his own medicine is interesting
nonetheless so here's nancy pelosi on
cnn
it is a pandemic that has gotten worse
before it will get better
because of his inaction and in fact
clearly
it is the trump virus
well what do you mean when you say the
trump virus the type virus if he had
said months ago let's wear a mask let's
not
let socially distance instead of having
rallies and political whatever they were
then more people would have followed his
lead as the president
of the united states instead of being a
bad example making it like a manhood
thing not to wear a mask
so any event was weird because
a briefing on the coronavirus should be
about science
and that is something the president has
ignored it should be about governance
and now he's finally embracing saying
okay it's okay to wear
a mask so i think a good deal of what we
have suffered
is clearly the trump virus now i know
that even within our audience there's a
split
on this type of thing what's the point
of these superficial things when nancy
pelosi has been part of
the failure to get substantive financial
relief to all americans people are
writing to me
you know this is crumbs when we need a
main course trump virus ooh okay
what about money for people who need it
i agree with you i agree with you but to
restate
this is not a replacement or an
alternative to anything that should have
been done and should be done and could
be done
failures remain failures whether they're
the democratic party or trump or the
republican party or whoever
but the attempt to brand trump
with the excess destruction of this
pandemic is not stupid
it's the number one issue right now for
voters in the 2020 election
more people than necessary have died
because of this administration's
mishandling of the coronavirus so if
it's the most
important issue to voters and according
to a recent poll it is
and trump has failed on it and it's one
of the biggest drags on donald trump's
approval
and we all understand that for the sake
of saving lives trump must be removed in
november
this is an opportunity that is not the
left
becoming destructive and stooping to the
level of the right
in a substantive way this is optics and
i think it's an opportunity to hit trump
with it
period and it should be done it's no
major thing but it's a dig and it could
trigger trump again
uh to react in an unhinged way doubling
the damage now you might remember
trump also likes to call coronavirus the
plague
the term trump plague is interesting to
me because it encompasses not just the
virus being the trump plague
but this administration being a plague
and beyond that
trump failing on the trump virus caused
the trump recession
he must be voted out before we have a
trump war there is a cohesive nature to
it that i don't think should be ignored
now by the way instead of starting a war
with another country trump is starting a
conflict
domestically between federal and local
law enforcement with these deployments
of paramilitaries to cities like
portland oregon
i talked to you earlier in the show
about donald trump's announcement
yesterday
that he's going to be deploying them to
chicago this is another version of
starting an armed conflict
but this one is within our borders
instead of beyond them which is often a
tool that presidents look to use
as they are approaching a possible
re-election so bottom line
political name calling is indeed
childish you are not wrong
but when it comes to this and this kind
of final sprint to try to remove donald
trump
democrats playing the games trump plays
when they don't lead to death and
destruction
i'm okay with but if we don't vote it's
all
bs it's just it's just wasted time we
have to vote
in november earlier if you have absentee
ballot access
if you have early voting access if we
don't this is all a waste of time
i hate wasting my time i like making
things happen i'm a pragmatist sometimes
people in the audience get mad at me
they say
you're being too pragmatic well listen
with all of this stuff
what matters is removing trump in
november and oh and by the way
maga flew also a reasonable alternative
for me to the trump virus
i'm really fine with whatever as long as
it points
to helping us remove this guy as soon as
possible
which is about three months and a week
from now
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219
to david p i spoke earlier this week
speaking of wasting time i spoke earlier
this week about
the possibility of the left
taking advantage of joe biden defeating
donald trump
to actually get things done from the
standpoint of progressive politics and
of course
democrats taking over the senate would
be a big part of that here's a caller
who is skeptical to say the least that
that's something democrats are going to
do take a listen
david are you serious you've got to be
joking
you're giving the democratic party as it
is right now
way too much credit for the game for
being able to hypothetically
take advantage of the dissension among
the ranks and on the republican side
if that was the case we would have done
it already it ain't going to happen
unless we first address the defaults in
this party
you have to get rid of the census
democratic leadership
otherwise everything else is an academic
exercise
and we don't have that much time for
academic talk anyway being how fist to
copy
the people on the far right are becoming
the brown shirts are coming
we better beef up so listen i i don't
disagree
generally speaking that the centrist
elements of the democratic party are
standing in the way of progressive
change and reform and i i
i agree there however you know the the
the idea that democrats have done
nothing the 2018 midterms were really
good for democrats in the house of
representatives now the
the map in the senate was not favorable
to democrats but
there were some in in 2018 in the
midterms this was one of the biggest
moves away from republicans and two
democrats in any recent congressional
election
and a lot of the people that won on the
democratic side in 2018
were some of the more progressives
member members of the house of
representatives so that was
that was the last real opportunity when
there have been state elections we've
seen states like virginia move left
we've seen a lot of different states
move left
and now this is the next opportunity so
let's not um
let's not get ahead of criticizing
democrats
there was an opportunity in 2018 and
it went almost as well as it could
possibly have gone
let's now see what happens in november
and then go from there the skepticism i
understand and it makes sense
but to say that there has been no
advantage taken
from the way that trump has uh sort of
divided the republican party
2018 is a pretty good example of
democrats making some significant gains
now of course we don't have the senate
uh
on our side and we don't have uh the
white house
so there's a limited amount that can be
done let's see what happens if democrats
are able to take the white house
in november and potentially take the
senate if not this november in november
of 2022
then we will analyze and go from there
we have a great bonus show for you today
we are going
to talk about um derek chavin
uh who has been charged in the killing
of george floyd also being charged
for tax evasion and i've got a bunch of
other great stories for you on the bonus
show two ways to get instant access
number one
become a member at jointpakman.com
number two
become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and you will then get
the bonus show
every single day it's a beautiful thing
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video